steve for reading your bio on your site
or an article about you
i understand that you taught improv back
in the 70s
in prisons you received a grant uh yeah
i was um
i was part of a company i was very young
back in the 70s
and so i was part of a group called
wings
and this was a group that had gotten a
grant to go to
prisons in virginia and uh with the idea
of teaching them improv
and it was kind of a a great um
slightly misguided effort but it was it
was really wonderful i mean we went into
a medium security prison a women's
prison and a maximum security prison
and we met amazing people in the and the
amazing thing is is those guys were
better improvisers than we were
we would come in and do a show you know
like a little scene
from an adaptation of check offs the you
know the the marriage proposal
or a scene from the musical you know
adam you know um
the apple tree you know where i played
adam
and then after we did that uh then we
would grab
a couple of uh about 10 or 12
inmates and we would teach them
a series of of improv lessons
usually lasting about a month and a half
and then we would go off to another
prison
and this one place that we went to i
understand
that they formed a group that kept on
performing
years after we left uh but the the weird
thing
is is that here were all here are these
four middle class
you know you know up with america kind
of group
and we i don't think we had ever um
encountered people like that uh you know
and uh
there was this one guy you know he's he
was called smiley
and uh smiley would have this big grin
and uh you know you're there with them
for
for weeks and so somebody asked him so
what'd you do to get here
and he said well i would walk into you
know burger king
and i would say you know give me a big
mac
and sing the song and we go sing the
song
yeah sing the song and then they said
we're not going to sing the song
then he would pull out this huge
revolver and he would say
sing the song and then he would make
them sing you know special orders
whatever the song was uh and then he
would drop them
and he was eventually caught uh there
was another guy
who had this picture of this woman he
said
what do you think of her and we would
say well she's pretty
yeah that's my wife i killed her you
know it was it was
surreal and the the one thing that i
got out of that is i don't know those
people i i don't know
how they live i don't i i rather than
oh i'm i've been in prisons for a couple
of days and i
know exactly everything there is to know
about this subculture and
i i left with the appreciation that
there's so
so much about so many people that i know
nothing about
at least having the respect of knowing
what i don't know
but it was a great training period for
me it was a great
learning experience and i took the
experience i learned
doing improv teaching improv and i used
that
a couple of years later to open a
theater company in new york called
manhattan punchline
where where i started teaching improv
not to not to prisoners
just to actors